most of my adult life i have taught
marxian economics
i'm a professor of economics i've been
that all my life
i'm a graduate of american
universities as it happens i'm a
graduate of what in this country passes
for its best universities
with another conversation you and i can
have
so i went to harvard then i went to
stanford and i finished the yale i'm
like a poster boy for elite education
they tried very hard by the way i had i
spent 10 years of my life in the ivy
league 20 semesters one after the other
no break in those 20 semesters 19 of
them never mentioned a word about
marxism
that is no critique of capitalism was
offered to me
ever with one except one professor
in stanford in the one semester i
studied with him he gave me plenty to
read but nobody else so
that's really interesting you've
mentioned that in the past and that's
very true which makes you a very
interesting figure
to hold your ground
intellectually
through this idea space where just
people
don't really even talk about it
perhaps we can discuss historically why
that is but nevertheless that's the case
so
marxian economics did karl marx come up
in conversation
as a kind of
dismissal
the best example yeah he came up only as
an object of dismissal for giving an
example
the major textbook in economics that i
was taught with and that be was for many
years the canonical book isn't quite
anymore um
was a book authored by a professor of
economics at mit named paul samuelson
and people kind of you know a whole
generation or two were trained on his
textbook if you open the cover of his
textbook he has a tree
and you know and the tree is adam smith
and david ricardo at the at the root and
then the different branches of he's
trying to give you an idea as a student
of how the thing developed
and it's a tree and everybody on it is
the bourgeois
and then there's this one little branch
that goes off like this and sort of
starts heading back down that's karl
marx in other words
he had to have it complete because she's
not a complete faker but beyond that no
there was no
nothing in the book gives you
two paragraphs
of an approach
but that's cold war i mean that that's
really that's really neither here that
that's the craziness yeah that's the
cold war in this country my professors
were afraid
you